I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense let me be aware of these
different parts of myself so I can
navigate yes and let me tell my partner
intimacy is into me I see
the more I know me the closer I can get
to you so when I tell my partner oh
listen Deborah I have so much energy you
really want me to go for a yoga class
right now or I'm gonna get real like I
know enough now about myself exactly
what I need to do to keep my fluid
energy going but if I go off my rhythm
because I'm dancing with the other and
all I doesn't matter if I do yoga or I
don't have to go for my run then all of
a sudden I'm off center and my observer
is suddenly going you know what you're
pissed off at him no you lost your
rhythm right that's your thing in this
life how do I keep my awareness on of
the other and the self without getting
caught in either extreme right right
relate to that so I do feel such a deep
yearning for the deepest truest kind of
love and sync like being in sync with
each other and understanding and having
there be literally no tension like
there's nothing there's no tension I
cannot have tension you're a master at
relation to your chart has the potential
to really do divine union Wow and that's
the deepest calling all my boyfriends
I'm gonna tell you we have because
you're Saturn isn't is in Libra like
your life lesson
Saturn tells us what your life lesson is
okay that's the Moke V my system when I
teach the most important planet is
Saturn it gives me all the clues of what
did someone sign up for and you're in a
major change as we sit here like your
chart is actively being opened the
seven-year cycle this year write about
the winter coming close to us of making
some big decisions life-changing
decision you'll remember this year as a
significant marker you should see your
face can you see your face yeah yeah
they're punched in real tight on it well
it's it's okay because I mean that's a
you know sometimes that can be scary
because you're like well it could go
wrong but it could go right but there's
really no wrong do you get scared yeah
so I look very far forward like I think
there I feel as though people tend to
either look back a lot or they look
forward a lot living in the present is
very challenging
I mean for anybody except a monk sitting
on a hill with the things we would be
present but I'm a look forward person so
I create a lot of attachments to
outcomes to how I see everything going
to a relationship to a job to a company
I really far forward which helps me be
motivated and get somewhere but if it
needs to go somewhere different than
where I've been looking I can take a
while to let go of it I used to think I
was a little slow or something was wrong
with me cuz I'm so here now and I found
out it was the high road that it was the
gift of a meditator because I would I
get so simple I'm so in the present that
it's a problem from when people start
future pacing I'm like wow that's
interesting you're already out there
it's a difficult it's a different
sensibility yeah I find it fascinating
to what this is my favorite thing how we
are all so different and how we dance
together so I hire someone to do what I
can't do and they count on me to bring
them into the now
[Music]